what is beauty well beauty is very
interesting because it's changed a lot
in the 20th century in a much
interesting way much more interesting
way than it used to be before when
Philip Johnson you know the great
curator and architect and pattern of mo
mine or he and one of the people that
interviewed me for my job and he was so
provocative I cannot tell you he did a
show called machine art in 1934 he took
propeller blades and coils and put them
on wed pedestals against white walls as
if they were brancusi sculptures because
he wanted to show people how beautiful
design can be but at that time he was
talking about platonic beauty he wanted
to show an absolute beauty something
that is above the fray of the world that
is universal and that everybody can
recognize now that idea completely burst
during the 20th century and you know I
used to be a punk so hey what can you
say you know beauty is so relative and
you can see that today beauty is really
up to the individual and it's more an
expression of something that is a
personal composition I used to say that
it's Madonna and Pedro Almodovar that
kind of destroyed the idea of platonic
beauty because if you look at the
almodovar actresses the ones that have
profiles that look like not even ski
slopes that are like completely vertical
it's beautiful Picasso women they're not
classical beauty they are a beauty that
is completely that is completely
subjective but at the same time because
it is so strong and subjective it
becomes universal so so much happened in
the 60s and 70s and 80s in terms of new
ideals of beauty in the body and human
beings the fact you know the first black
model on the cover of Vogue you know
just all of these different changes or
even the dove commercial last year with
the kind of heavyset women showing that
they were beautiful too when it comes to
the human body you can go through this
narration very easily when it comes to
design it's not that different you can't
anymore talk about a certain platonic
beauty but it's more
about what people see in the object it's
more about communication and meaning
that in today's about form